>> Judge Jeanine: IT PAYS BIG
TO BE A TOTAL LOSER IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THE ATLANTIC
QUESTIONING WHY DEMOCRATS KEEP
FALLING FOR SUPERSTAR LOSERS
STACEY ABRAMS AND BETO O'ROURKE
WHO SEEM LIKE THEY COULD NOT
EVEN GET ELECTED DOG CATCHER.
BOTH CAMPAIGNS ARE ON TRACK TO
GET CRUSHED IN THEIR MIDTERM
RACES DESPITE THEIR CAMPAIGNS
RAISING $170 MILLION TO UNSEAT
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS IN GEORGIA
AND TEXAS.
BUT IT IS REALLY NO WONDER WITH
MOMENTS LIKE THIS.
>> SO, I AM HERE AT THE DENTIST,
AND WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE OUR
SERIES ON THE PEOPLE OF THE
BOARD ROOM.
>> AT THE BAR NEXT DOOR, THE
CEILING IS TOO LOW.
HERE WE GO!
NOW I CAN SEE EVERYBODY.
>> THANK YOU FOR WELCOMING US
HERE TODAY TO OHIO.
>> I'M RUNNING TO SERVE YOU AS
AN EX-PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
IT'S BECOME LOOKING FORWARD TO
CELEBRATING THE VICTORY ON THE
6TH OF NOVEMBER!
>> RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR AND I
WANT TO TELL YOU WHY.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY,
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR, HE DID NOT
TELL US WHY, DO YOU THINK HE HAS
ANY GOOD IDEAS OTHER THAN WHO WE
ARE GOING TO TAKE YOUR AR-15?
>> Greg: HIS ONLY IDEA IS TO
TURN CAMPAIGNING INTO A CAREER
AND LIVE OFF THE DONATIONS.
IT'S A WEIRD WORLD WHEN YOU CAN
LOSE THE RACE FOR CONGRESS AND
IT DOES NOT MATTER BECAUSE THE
NEXT STEP IS RUNNING FOR
GOVERNOR.
BETO O'ROURKE HAS DONE NOTHING
LIKE REAL WORK EXCEPT MAKE HIS
LIFE FREE OF WORK.
AND IT DOES NOT MATTER.
I THINK THAT THEY HAVE TURNED,
IT'S A GREAT SCAM IS WHEN I AM
SAYING.
IT'S A GREAT SCAM.
I'M JEALOUS.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO REALLY WORK.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY,
ALL RIGHT, SO YOU HAVE STACEY
ABRAMS WHO SAYS I'M NOT AN
ELECTION DENIER, BUT NEVER
CONCEDED THE ELECTION.
AND YOU HAVE PEOPLE WHO STILL
GIVE THESE LOSERS MONEY.
WHY?
>> Jesse: THE TWO FAVORITE
PRESIDENTS OF THE LIBERALS JFK
AND BARACK OBAMA, THEY ARE
TRYING TO RECREATE THAT.
THEY THINK THEIR FRANCHISES.
LET'S DO A SECOND ACT.
THEY SEE STACEY ABRAMS, YOU ARE
BLACK, YOU'RE THE NEXT
BARACK OBAMA, AND THEY SEE
BETO O'ROURKE, HE HAD WEARS A
BUTTON DOWN AND COLLEGE GIRLS
LIKE A SMILE, CAMELOT!
IT DOES NOT WORK LIKE THAT.
YOU CAN'T BE A LIBERAL AND WIN
IN TEXAS OR GEORGIA.
YOU CAN BE A DEMOCRAT AND HAVE A
SHOT, BUT CAN'T BE RADICAL LEFT.
>> Judge Jeanine: WHAT DO YOU
THINK OF PEOPLE LIKE BETO WHO IS
MARRIED TO A WEALTHY WOMAN AND
HAS NOT HAD A REAL JOB JUST LIKE
FETTERMAN.
WHAT IS WITH THESE GUYS?
>> Jessica: HE WAS A
CONGRESSMAN, WHICH LAST TIME I
CHECKED WAS A REAL JOB.
>> Judge Jeanine: HOW LONG DID
HE HAVE IT?
>> Jessica: A FEW YEARS.
AS THE ONLY PERSON THAT DONATES
TO DEMOCRATS HERE.
SO I KNOW I WILL VOTE BLUE AND
LOOK AT ALL OF THE NAMES, AND I
WILL TRY TO FIND THE MOST BORING
PERSON.
AND MY DAD THE MOST UNSEXIEST
PERSON MICHAEL BENNET.
HE WAS LIKE THIS IS A TYPE OF
PERSON THAT WILL BORE YOU TO
DEATH, BUT HE WILL BE GOOD AND
HE WILL BE MEASURED AND HE WILL
GET THINGS DONE.
AND OBVIOUSLY HE LOST, BUT YOU
SHOULD NOT FALL FOR THESE KINDS
OF THINGS.
AND I WONDER WITH THINGS LIKE
SHERRY BEASLEY FOR INSTANCE IN
NORTH CAROLINA, I DON'T THINK
THAT VAL DEMINGS WOULD'VE ONE
MAN, BUT YOU CAN FIND THEM ALSO
FUN AND INTERESTING WHO HAVE A
SHOT AT WINNING THE RACES AND
GIVE THEM MONEY.
>> Dana: THERE IS A DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN BIG FANCY
BEAUTIFUL COVER STORY IN A
MAGAZINE AND FAILURE ON A
STATEWIDE RACE.
IN ONE OF THE THINGS THAT HAPPEN
WITH THESE TWO IS THAT THEY ARE
DRAGGING DOWN ALL OF THE DOWN
BALLOT RACES.
WE TALKED TO HENRY ON
"AMERICA'S NEWSROOM" AND ASKED
AND SAID DO YOU THINK HE IS
HELPING YOU A QUESTION MARK HE
DID NOT SAY NO, BUT HE DID NOT
SAY YES.
YOU TRY TO WALK A LINE.
HE KNOWS THAT HE IS NOT HOPING
HIM, WE KNOW FROM DATA THAT
STACEY ABRAMS IS DRAGON DOWN --
SO FROM A REPUBLICAN PERSPECTIVE
THEY WOULD SAY THAT DEMOCRATS